>> Tucker: THE HITS KEEP COMING
FROM FACEBOOK.
FIRST THE COMPANY WAS ROCKED BY
THE REVELATION THAT CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICA HARVESTED DATA AND NOW
THE COMPANY IS ACCUSEDS ITSELF
OF DATA COLLECT.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN SPYING ON
PEOPLE.
IT WAS REPORTED THAT FACEBOOK
COLLECTED CONTACTS AND TEXT
MESSAGES FROM ANDROID PHONE
USERS WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> HAPPY TO BE HERE, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: ONE TAKE IS IT SEEMS
LIKE THE REST OF THE COUNTRY IS
WAKING UP TO THE BASIC NATURE OF
FACEBOOK.
IT SPIES ON YOU.
>> I THINK THAT THE ISSUE IS
EXACTLY AS YOU FRAMED IT.
THE BUSINESS MODEL, WHICH IS
BASED ON ADVERTISING, REQUIRES
THEM TO KNOW AS MUCH AS THEY CAN
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE USER.
WHAT YOU CAN'T TELL AS A USER IS
THEY ARE USING EVERY TOOL
AVAILABLE.
ANDUJAR
ANDUJA
ANDROA
ANDROID
ANDROID P
ANDROID PHO
ANDROID PHONE
ANDROID PHONES
ANDROID PHONES A
ANDROID PHONES ALL
ANDROID PHONES ALLOW
ANDROID PHONES ALLOWS
ANDROID PHONES ALLOWS FA
ANDROID PHONES ALLOWS FACE
ANDROID PHONES ALLOWS FACEBO
ANDROID PHONES ALLOWS FACEBOOK
TO DOWN LOAD ALL OF YOUR
CONTACTS AND TEXTS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DISCOVERED THAT
IT'S NOT JUST CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICA.
FROM 2010 TO 2014 THERE WERE
TENS OF THOUSANDS AND MAYBE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
APPLICATIONS THAT HARVESTED ALL
OF THIS USER DATA WITHOUT THE
PERMISSION OF THE USER.
>> Tucker: THAT GIVES FACEBOOK
MORE POWER OVER YOU KNOW THAT
ANY GOVERNMENT HAS HAD OVER
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
SHOULD WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT THAT
POWER?
>> THAT REQUIRES GREAT JUDGMENT
AND FACEBOOK'S JUDGMENT AROUND
THIS POWER HAS BEEN POOR.
MY TENURE THERE FROM 2006 TO
2009, WAS BEFORE THE COMPANY
DEVELOPED A BUSINESS MODEL.
SO I WAS WITHDRAWN WHILE THIS
WAS GOING ON.
AS I CAME TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
GOING ON, I FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO REACH OUT TO MARK
ZUCKERBERG AND SARAH SANDBERG
AND MAKE THEM AWARE OF IT.
IT'S HARD TO RECOGNIZE YOUR BABY
IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
BUT I AM AFRAID IT HAS.
CANDIDLY I AM GLAD THESE
REVELATIONS ARE COMING OUT
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO CHANGE
THEIR STRATEGIES.
>> Tucker: ANDROID USERS ARE BE
SPIED ON UPON.
WILL WE LEARN THAT ABOUT APPLE?
>> NO, APPLE HAS A DIFFERENT
STRUCTURE.
IN
IN AP
IN APPL
IN APPLE'
IN APPLE'S
IN APPLE'S M
IN APPLE'S MOD
IN APPLE'S MODEL
IN APPLE'S MODEL P
IN APPLE'S MODEL PEO
IN APPLE'S MODEL PEOPL
IN APPLE'S MODEL PEOPLE
IN APPLE'S MODEL PEOPLE P
IN APPLE'S MODEL PEOPLE PAY
DIRECTLY TO APPLE.
IN FACEBOOK WHERE THE ADVERTISER
IS THE CUSTOMER AND THE USER IS
THE PRODUCT.
THE USER TO ANDROID IS ALSO A
PRODUCT.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THEY ARE NOT TREATING US LIKE
HUMANS.
THEY ARE TREATING US LIKE FUEL
TO GENERATE PROFITS.
THAT HAS TO STOP.
SILICONE VALLEY HAS TO RECOGNIZE
THEY CAN STILL BE BILLIONAIRES
WITHOUT STRIPPING PRIVACY AND
SELLING IT TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER.
>> Tucker: IT TOOK GOVERNMENT 40
YEARS TO RESPOND TO THE HEALTH
EFFECTS OF TOBACCO.
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE OUR
GOVERNMENT TO RESPOND TO THE BAD
EFFECTS OF FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE?
>> I DON'T THINK THE BEST
RESPONSE WILL BE FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
IT WILL BE FROM THE USERS AND
THE EMPLOYEES THESE COMPANIES.
I DON'T THINK THE EMPLOYEES
UNDERSTOOD WHAT THE COMPANIES
WERE DOING.
WAIT A MINUTE, THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THEY WANT TO BE PART
OF IT.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE SOME KIND
OF PUSH BACK AND REBELLION.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE THE EMPLOYS
OF FACEBOOK TO DO IS RECOGNIZE
THAT, HEY, WAIT A MINUTE, THESE
ARE GREAT IDEAS.
BUT THE ADVERTISING BUSINESS
MODEL HAS TERRIBLE INCENTIVES
AND BILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE HURT
BY IT.
NOT JUST IN THE U.S. BUT AROUND
THE WORLD.
FRANKLY, THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL
WITHOUT DOING THAT STUFF.
IT'S ON THE EMPLOYEES TO FIX.
IT THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T FIX THIS
ON A TIME FRAME THAT WOULD MAKE
DIFFERENCE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.